well phaedra parks she's an actress now
she is
how did this come about
acting is always a natural progression
for anyone that's you know a tv
personality i
heard about this role and was like wow
this sounds so interesting i'd love to
read it i read it and i said i want to
audition because they said we'll just
give you a part and i said no i want to
audition and i want to earn the role
that i want i auditioned and i got the
role that i wanted which was bernice the
wife of the very wealthy conroy
whitfield we didn't want to alarm anyone
until we knew the full scope of his
condition and as his wife i agreed that
we needed to do what was best for our
family this character bernice whitfield
is the last name any relationship ray
you know what it's funny i never even
thought about that but i guess she could
embody uh you know i could see a little
charade in her you know yeah or like
cousin cheray comes sits at this exactly
yeah
yeah she you know they could definitely
be in the family because you know
charade does love the finer things in
life
and so does bernice so bernice likes
some fine things some shiny things
charade does this is true cheray is
re-entering the world of real housewives
soon as are you you signed yourself back
up for a show
well they actually pulled me into it i
went kicking and uh screaming the whole
time but no um i'm on the match-up show
and then oh what a great oh interesting
time it was awesome but i mean y'all are
gonna love it because it is the epitome
of everything housewives the whole
series is about you know very uh
dramatic very
scandalous a lot of secrets revealed
a lot of drinking a lot of crying a lot
of screaming and of course a lot of
fighting so that's you know the top
rated show for any roblox all the boxes
checked there which is the boxers which
is more dramatic and salacious the
master cup show or covenant well it's
different because covenant obviously
you're playing a role so you know what's
going to happen the mashup show you
don't see it coming it just
happens and you're like oh my god what
if
i what if i sign myself up for like this
is crazy but yeah both totally different
but but equally as juicy okay equally as
juicy great tv dorinda medley told me
she really bonded with you that you and
eva were like her girls at blue stone
man you know what i love the rinda
medley i think
she is my spirit animal you know i love
to make things nice she is very
extravagant
she loves to entertain and everybody
knows honey i love a party i love
everything fabulous but she is a
spitfire now she does not back away from
a fight
so that was
you know she's so cute
and so you know just perfect and you
know she's got this little dragon in i'm
just like
yeah she's uh she's unassuming and then
you know there's the the phrase from her
time on her show of she's starting
his word on the street is it's her
versus vicky this whole time i wouldn't
say that i mean i i
wouldn't say that no i mean
vicki uh you know and i
i loved everybody i know that sounds
crazy but i really did because it was
just so different i mean there was so
many you know every ever all of us have
big personalities but you know vicki was
going through some things vicki
definitely brought her own set of
problems that had nothing to do with us
but i mean i think people will resonate
with what she's going through but then i
think you know some of the you know
shall we say the disagreements people
will uh be very interesting as well
i am sure there's a lot to unpack there
did it make you miss your peach at all
or was it like
no no
italian but i don't want to pick that
peach back up full time okay no you know
what it was great because these are
different women and at the end of the
day
we were at the manor which is absolutely
gorgeous you know we were there for a
couple of weeks so you know that there
is a end date you know so you get in and
you get out and that was fun you know
and we were able to i became friends
with all of them and i've kept in touch
with every single one of them afterwards
and so that's good because you know when
you're doing it
in your own city it's it's a different
scenario right this is now you got
friends all over the country i saw you
and randy glanville together that's a
dangerous combination that i like
i love randy brandi is so misunderstood
she is a joy
she's just an angel with you know just a
sprinkle of devilishness on her but
she's she's sweetie she's a sprinkle of
devilishness um all right so you are you
are very happy in where you are right
now you don't want to return to
housewives anytime soon we've talked
about that before but what is next for
you is acting the thing you're you're
pursuing right now um you're a lawyer
mortician reality star tv personality
fitness expert mom
you know what's next
i mean i really love acting people when
they
when they understand that you're acting
versus in reality world it's a different
sort of conversation because not that
every honey not that anything is real in
reality but people make that assumption
that everything that they're seeing is
you know truthful and it's you know this
is what it is and so this is great to
really be playing a character
and be able to walk away from it and
people understand that hey that's a
character so what's the dream role
bernice sounds like it checked a lot of
boxes for you but when you think about
what you would like to get your hands on
what might challenge you what is that
role well i would love to play something
where i can you know action pack you
know maybe i can you know do a couple of
flips how about you wanna do kill bill
three okay
[Applause]
you know kill bill free with the little
mother steward thrown in there you know
okay she yeah she's making pies and
picks up that knife and chucks it at
somebody else yeah
you know something you know but i love
the stuff that's very interesting like
you know like the harder they fall
that's good stuff or squid games like i
would love to do something that's very
different from who i am as uh you know
woman every day you know something
that's just totally opposite of me would
you look for projects that your boys
could see because i know up until now
nothing you've done they can really
watch oh they can't watch
no um i would love to do something even
in the space with children aiden would
love to act so he is actually audition
for a role model too so it's something
that he's interested into but they are
my they're my coaches i they do the the
lines with me and they practice with me
so they've been super helpful do they
give you um feedback well you know
sometimes it's like mom change your
voice you sound you know that doesn't
sound right you know that's lame
and then in personal life last time we
talked you were doing marriage boot camp
i believe that relationship fizzled
where are we at what are we looking for
for a place
i'm just a free agent you know
to be honest um i've been working and
traveling so much now that they've sort
of opened up the floodgates for travel i
really haven't been focused on of course
i go on dates but
that hasn't been my focus because i'm
really happy i've been super busy and i
don't know if i really have
time to devote to a super serious
committed relationship so let's you know
let's just go i have fun and you know
you're enjoying the single life
yeah the single life is a good life i'm
a pound cake i don't need anything
pound cakes are delicious all by
themselves you know you can add a little
whipped cream or ice cream but honey you
could just eat it by yourself at night
and it's
oh so tasty
people have picked up on you've elevated
your look we'll say as of late you're
going with the long blonde hair the fits
are getting a little tighter is that a
conscious choice or just a style
evolution you know what i got a new hair
stylist who i would have never had i
would have never thought about doing
blind but
for a role i was considering doing they
had asked about have you ever thought
about blonde and so that's how the
blonde came to be everyone loved it so
much and it was so different and you
know i i didn't know blondes had this
much fun you know and i always had a few
highlights but now i'm really like ashy
blonde you know and it's just
you know the boys like to you know this
this is the milkshake honey and it's
bringing the boys to the yard honey i've
got a pound cake we've got milkshake
we've got a whole soda shop happening
here
okay this is a dessert tray
dig in
take a nibble um all right what is the
number one reason for people to
subscribe to all black and tune in for
at least your two episodes of this
anthology series the number one reason
to subscribe to all black is because
i'm on this show
but they've got great content you'll
love it you will definitely it won't be
a penny wasted call me i'll give you a
money-back guarantee
i love it and then for all stars i know
we gotta wait a minute for that for the
mashup show but what do you think is
gonna surprise viewers the most about
those episodes wow it's uh some secrets
that are revealed that's like
wow and i think for me it clears up a
lot of the old stuff from atlanta as
well so that's that's the thing about
these shows is you get to break the
fourth wall and dig into the things that
are left unsaid uh on the actual shows
so that will be you know that's
something everyone saw you know what
happened what happened so you get to
find that out when i tell you it is
action-packed from the minute we got to
blue stone manor honey
honey it was every color of the rainbow
plus sun plus some lesson the peacock
feathers were in full bloom so
people are gonna love it it is classic
housewives well i'm looking forward to
it i'm glad you get to say
at least some of your piece officially
in the housewives world on what went
down that's a good note to end on i
think yes